[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRASER MACDONALD:
I'm Fraser Macdonald.
I'm a product guy at Google
working on Cloud IoT.
So IoT Core as a product,
and a lot of the extended IoT
ecosystem that Google has
got a lot of offerings in.
I'm really excited to
have you here today
for a pretty specific topic.
And it's one that when we were
putting this talk together,
we were really excited to do.
Because with a
smaller audience, you
get a chance to chat about
something that's actionable.
So we want to talk today
about some real specifics
of replatforming.
Because it's a terrifying
thing to a lot of companies,
but it's a huge mover for
a lot of companies as well.
So just to get us
kicked off, as a bit
of an idea of who's sitting in
the audience, how many people
here have actually gone through
it, some form of technology
replatforming,
themselves in the past?
Sure, yeah, a good amount
of the group that's probably
felt the pains and struggles and
the benefit on the other side.
What about been part
of a company that's
discussed a replatforming
but decided against it?
A little bit, yeah.
Those conversations
come up, too.
So we wanted to make sure to
cover some of the specifics
today, and we're
excited to do it.
So I want to start
by asking you this--
how many of these
buzzwords and technology
trends over the years either
strike fear in your heart,
because you were
part of the team
responsible for what are
we going to do about this,
or are a fond memory of
something we've gone through?
Personally, Y2K is the one
that stands out for me.
I grew up in a house with a
dad who was a disaster recovery
planner, professionally,
for a bank.
And so Y2K rolled around,
and it was his job
to make sure that the Canadian
Imperial Bank of Commerce
didn't go under because of Y2K.
If you can't tell a Canadian
accent, that's where it's from.
So we had a bunker in our
basement full of canned foods.
So I still have associations
of fears of, what's
going to go wrong with Y2K?
But each one of these
is a technology trend
that's happened over
the last 15, 20 years.
And each one of these is
also a real opportunity.
When the rise of mobile
started coming in earnest,
companies realized they needed
to adopt new strategies so
that their businesses were
capable of handling mobile.
When e-commerce
started springing up,
companies realized, we need
to do some pretty significant
technical overhaul
so that we can
make sure we can sell all
of our product online.
And we're kind of getting
to that point in the IoT
now as well.
As the IoT is getting
more mature and more
both consumer and industrial
products are launching
that are connected
to the internet
either just as sensor networks
or sensors and actuators
that you're talking back
to, these technologies
are starting to get codified.
We're starting to get a few
more protocols emerging.
We're starting to get a
common understanding of what
are the building blocks
of device management,
of handling the
data, and how do we
tie users into the ecosystem.
And as this is happening,
it's following the same trends
as a lot of these did.
Companies are realizing,
OK, I started with a POC,
and we put something together
internally that worked,
and we built or we had an
SI shop that built for us.
But we want to take
it production grade.
So at Google, we're having
a lot of conversations
about replatforming, and I think
there's a big reason for it.
And that's we're hitting the
point where companies are not
all green field anymore.
There are a lot of
companies out there today
that have some form of
connected product in the market,
it's got a bit of
internet connectivity,
and they're looking at
going to the next generation
of the product.
They stuck one out there.
It was a pilot project.
They got success with it.
And they're almost victims
of their own success,
realizing we need
to scale things out.
We need to be able to
roll out a new feature
that we didn't anticipate.
And so a lot of
the conversations
that we're having at
Google are with companies
who have something
stood up already
and need to figure out
how to integrate it.
It's a common conversation.
So we're seeing
roughly two camps
of companies that are going
through replatforming.
One is motivated by the pushes.
It's we built something that
was meant for a couple thousand
users, and we'd like to be
able to handle a couple hundred
thousand.
Or one of the major
pieces of technology
that we are reliant on
is going out of business,
and we need to
make accommodations
for this yesterday.
A lot of it also is things are
getting out of hand because we
didn't build this
to scale, and we're
running our own infrastructure,
and we can't keep the costs up.
Another big push
factor is I'm not sure
that our technical
team in-house is
the one that should be focusing
entirely on our IoT product.
We need them for other things.
Just as often, there is
something on the other side.
There's the pull factors.
And that's what we
were talking about.
New technologies are emerging.
New standards are emerging.
IoT Core as a product that the
Xively acquisition from January
and the IoT core
product in Google
are coming together to
provide is device management
as a service.
It's connectivity.
It's device security.
It's communication
over known protocols.
A lot of these
technologies in the IoT
are starting to
become standards,
and companies want to
take advantage of that.
I don't want to run
my own message broker.
I don't want to run my own
relationship between users
and devices.
Similarly, they want
to take advantage
of the teams that are
building at other companies
so their own team
doesn't have to.
If you can piggyback off of
somebody's real time database
technology, or you can handle
string processing or analytics
through a software
as a service tool,
it means that your team of
two, three, 10 engineers
in-house can focus
on something that's
just specific to your business.
So there are a lot of reasons
why this conversation is
coming up at companies.
But just as often,
there are a lot
of reasons why it's terrifying,
and the conversations are slow.
I had a conversation with
somebody recently who--
the quote from
him was, you know,
replatforming is not a
great way to get promoted,
but it's an excellent
way to get fired.
And I think it's a
common sentiment.
Because there's a lot of fear
around the idea of taking
a plane that's flying in the
air and swapping out the engine,
taking a product
that's already launched
in your customers' hands.
And you know that you
can get better out of it,
but you're really afraid of
touching something that's
already out there in the field.
And there are real risks.
You don't want to be
the company that's
on the front of the newspaper
because your product shut off.
Somebody pushed a firmware
image that they shouldn't
have had permission to push,
and they bricked 10,000 devices.
Or you don't want to be the
company that's wasting time
and gets the call
from your exec that
says, why is my
engineering team working
on building a new device
connectivity layer?
Don't we already have that?
And you don't have
a good answer.
What's the ROI of why we're
switching over to something?
So we wanted to take some time
when we are putting together
the talk today to address
these points head on.
They're real, practical
considerations,
and they don't often get
talked about directly.
So we're hoping to do that
in a bit of a unique format.
What we're going to
do is talk through
some of the best
practices that Rick
from Augusta, who is going
to come up and join me
in a minute as an SI, and
myself working on the platform
side of IoT have seen emerge.
When companies
are going through,
what are the best practices?
What are some of the things
you should take away?
And Rick's going to walk us
through a couple of examples
of companies that have actually
been there and done that,
and how they made it happen.
Because tackling these problems
should not be enormous,
and while they should
weigh all of these risks,
these risks should not stop
you from getting the benefits.
So I'm going to invite
Rick up, and let's
take a look at a couple
of these best practices.
So the first one we're
going to talk about
is Run a Tracer Bullet.
And for those who aren't
familiar with the expression,
a tracer bullet's meant to
indicate, what's something
that we can do end to end?
What's something
that we can carve out
as a small piece of
our working solution
and go through the
process from start
to finish with maybe a
subset of our customers,
or maybe one site only?
Because you're going
to run into problems.
You're going to need to
answer the call at 2:00 AM
because something's broken.
You're going to
realize that you forgot
that your users had to log in
through a new system instead
of an old system.
You're going to
realize that, oh,
yeah, that particular device
isn't capable of holding
a firmware image that big.
Something is going to go wrong.
And so one of the best
practices you can take away
is pick a site.
In an industrial
context, maybe it's
one site that was
an early customer
and who will be very
forgiving and really
eager to try out some of the new
technology you're rolling out.
Or if it's a consumer context,
pick a subset of your users
that might be power users, and
might be a bit more forgiving,
and walk through the
whole process with them.
And to give a bit of an idea in
real terms of what we've seen,
this is what we recommend
for how you stage things out.
You want to spend a good amount
of time on that Tracer Bullet.
Three to six months
should go into--
after you've had
the conversation
and you've justified why
are we making this change,
how much time should
you be looking
at putting towards this?
Spend up to six months
with that early customer
to make sure that the
people on your support team
know what they're doing, the
people on the technical side
know exactly what they're doing.
You've actually gone through the
process of pressing the button
and feeling the fear.
Because that's going to
make each of these stages
down the road work
a lot more smoothly.
Running in parallel
is just a great idea
in any replatforming and
rolling out any new technology.
It's sometimes thought of
as, you know, blue-green.
That you have a live
deployment and you're
swapping in-- getting
something up and running
before you're swapping
it into your whole fleet.
And finally, the crossover
stage is pretty quick
once you've walked
through all of this.
So I'm going to turn it over to
Rick to talk a bit about a case
where he's seen exactly this.
RICK ERICKSON:
Thank you, Fraser.
And thanks everybody
for having me up.
I'm Rick Erickson.
I'm actually a chief class
strategist at Augusta,
and I also run very specifically
our IoT practice area.
And so I've had the
pleasure of working
with a number of really
interesting companies
at different stages
of replatform.
And one of them that I want to
tell you about really quickly
is a company called Limelight.
This is a very
innovative company.
They launched a product
actually about nine years ago
in the industrial lighting
and control space.
They had originally a vision
for taking a zigbee mesh
and finding use cases they
could implement that mesh in
and ended up partnering
with some very large
lighting control
components and working
with some of the providers
that actually delivered
these lights at both the
industrial scale, parking,
and some other locations,
and found wild success.
And a very interesting
company in that, you
know, as you describe,
the use cases
of companies that
sort of tested an idea
and realized some level
of success initially.
But then were sort of, as
a result of their success,
ended up having challenges down
the road because they didn't
scale appropriately
or were stuck
with an architecture
that was dated and needed
to be modernized.
Limelight certainly fills that.
So with Limelight, you know,
one of the things that they
had a challenge
with was, we want
to modernize our entire
stack, but we kind of
don't know where to start.
And so we also haven't
partnered with anybody outside
of our engineering
team in the past.
So how do we do
that in a way that
allows us to sort
of test that concern
but also solve problems
inside our stack of services
that were the most impactful?
And so in Limelights
case, they happened
to have an MVNO that
acquired technology.
This is a technology that had
been acquired by three or four
other companies.
And this acquisition
of technology
was really no more than
a connection broker.
This is sort of in the
world prior to platforms,
and this company had a
proprietary connection
broker that was right in
the middle of their stack.
And they had a lot of
concerns about this stack
going end-of-life
and being stuck with,
what do we do if these
guys go out of business?
We have hundreds of
customers, huge customers,
like the parking garage
here at Moscone and others,
that use our technology.
And these organizations
would literally
have concerns about
configurations
going offline and being
able to manage them
if they were end-of-life.
And so for them, a big part
of their vision around this
is, how do we validate that
this important plumbing
in between our devices
and our back office
is going to function as
appropriate and as expected?
So let me tell you
kind of how we did it.
So I'm not going to get too
deep into the architecture,
but I want to give you
kind of some sense of where
they were at.
So I mentioned
their initial state.
I just mentioned they were
using this third-party MVNO.
They have a proprietary gateway
that's speaking, basically,
a proprietary protocol.
And that server in the
middle is where the MVNO
is hosting this broker.
And on the edge of the
application services,
it could read and
interpret that data
coming from these zigbee
devices on the end.
And so what we wanted
to do is literally
kind of think about this
as a canary in a coal mine.
Their use cases are they have
a multi-tenant system that's
deployed.
They also have customers that
have regulatory restrictions
that require them to deploy
their entire technology stack
in an isolated premise cloud.
So they have two concerns that
they have to kind of validate
for.
And so what we did
was we actually
set up a common
ISO-certified broker
that would run on Cloud
Platform but also be
containerized and capable of
operating in a hybrid scenario,
as well, or on the prem.
So again, fairly simple
problem, but in order
to make sure that we
had literally a tracer
bullet running from edge
to edge of this system,
we wanted to validate that there
weren't going to be problems
in both scenarios.
And they certainly
wanted to determine
that they had the right partner
to help them in this journey.
So the end result was we were
able to basically horseshoe
in this broker service,
rewrite the MQTT client
on the edge for the gateway.
And so we were supporting the
same hardware that was already
living at the edge--
no changes to that
hardware at all--
and then support a client
broker that could also interpret
the messaging coming back.
And so this was a
service on the edge.
That was a service on the edge.
This was a service
in the back end.
And then we implemented
basically kind
of a bridge that allowed us to
put a canary in the coal mine
and validate that from
the edge to edge we
were able to reduce that risk.
It would function as expected.
And so our first
deployments for them--
and this is one of the sort
of the learnings from this--
is deploy at an isolated
environment that doesn't affect
all of your tenants at once.
Have that be your
starting point.
So good learning there.
And then, pick
something that is going
to be relatively impactful
but not necessarily impact
all of your customers at once.
And so we took that
initial tracer bullet,
ran it through,
validated it, and then
moved to the multi-tenant
deployment after that.
So that was our first
set of learning.
I'm going to pass this back off.
FRASER MACDONALD: Great.
Thanks, Rick.
And I should say, as we're
going through these customer use
cases, too, we're going
to have an opportunity,
after we go through
four examples with you,
to chat with the companies.
We're going to have a Q&A
and invite the companies up
to speak about
their experiences.
So if you get a
question as you're
going through that
we don't cover,
make sure to jot it down.
Remember there's going
to be a mic at the end.
So the second one is
understanding your change
tolerance.
And this is an important
one, especially as you're
communicating a
replatforming story
through your own organization.
There's a lot of fear
of how big this can get.
And it's a reasonable fear.
And what we've noticed,
in a couple of rounds
of replatforming
with many companies,
is that there are
roughly three patterns.
You can go all the way
from light, medium,
through to heavy.
And you need to know, as
a company going into this,
how strategic is this to us?
And how much risk
tolerance do we have?
How much change
And what's the timeline
going to look like?
So a replatform does not have
to be an enormous takeover
all at once.
The light option here is perhaps
replacing a single component,
or supplementing a
single component.
This can be taking an
architecture that's already
using one flavor of MQTT
for device communication
and moving to a different
MQTT device broker.
Not much of an interruption,
and you can do it piecemeal.
It's a much easier sell if
you're doing it in parts.
The mid-size ones
are where you're
adding a couple of different
new pieces to the mix.
You might need to take
in a new data format.
Or you might be working
on live databases.
And this is where
it can get tricky,
because you're going to have
to be doing some hot swapping.
The heaviest of the replatforms
are full re-architectures.
And it's almost
never recommended.
In fact, if you're thinking
about a replatforming problem,
I guarantee you you
can break it down
into smaller, bite-sized pieces.
And we'll talk in a bit as well
that it's probably pretty easy
if you sit down with you
and your executive team
and the business people
in your organization
to identify, what's
the one thing that's
going to have the most impact?
You're going to know.
So each of the sizes
of these replatformings
is something that you
have to know as a company.
So Rick, I'm hoping
you can walk us
through an example of exactly
this style of decision-making.
RICK ERICKSON: Yeah, you bet.
So let me tell you a
story about-- actually,
we're lucky enough to have
one of the innovators of this
platform that was developed
by Group ADO here,
and you'll talk to him
when we do our Q&A.
But Group ADO is a
municipal busing--
both short haul, long
haul, and delivery
busing-- one of the largest
in Latin America and Spain.
And they have a really number
of innovation programs that
are built out for
their consumers,
and ways to sort of
track driver behavior,
a series of services that are
called SIIAB that are actually
quite sophisticated and were
built almost 15 years ago now
to support those user needs.
And these are outfitted across
the bulk of their fleet.
And one of the
challenges that they had
was opportunities to
add innovative services
across these existing services.
But also, how do
they figure out how
to take this sort of
legacy stack of services
and implement them in
a more modernized way?
And again-- sophisticated,
complicated, buses-moving
set of services.
So let me-- this is our
replatforming patterns.
We just covered
that, did we not?
I'm going the wrong way.
Sorry.
OK.
So what ADO really
wanted to do is
they've got an innovator
that was thinking about,
what are the
opportunities for me
to take my existing
stack of services
and implement more innovative
problems using machine
learning and analytics?
And I want to start
with, how can I
figure out both
the impact of that
and understand what's capable?
And at the same time,
I've got this legacy stack
of services that are being
used to deliver my existing
product to market.
I can't blow that up, because
that's got to still operate.
And I also need
to consider, where
are the places throughout my
stack of services, my hardware
stack, that is going to impact
the organization the most?
So at the edge, they've got a
relatively expensive computing
device that effectively will
handle all the communication
between the bus driver, the
systems inside providing
services to consumers
that can pay
using paid services
on a mobile device,
but also provide entertainment
services on the bus
and other behavioral analytics.
And that piece of device is a
proprietary embedded Windows
device that's very expensive
for them to not only source
but also to maintain
and provide longer-term.
So the use case that I
described is not uncommon.
We find a lot of companies
that have older and aged
infrastructure at the edge.
They need to figure out ways
of, how can they replace that
with a lower-cost device
that can be more readily
sourced but also still provide
the same level of compute
and intelligence that they
need to support their existing
set of services?
I'm sure that all of you
maybe have had experiences
with using really
dated technology
and seeing how it works.
And this is the same
concern that ADO had.
So we decided that we would
help them on this journey
by helping them stand up a
feasibility proof of concept
that would validate that they
could support this larger
vision for advanced services
and be able to also begin
to start materializing a model
for an edge computing device
that would be much less
expensive to source,
to build materials for,
and also provide a higher
level of performance to support
the vision that, in this case,
Verne and his team had to
validate that this was even
possible.
So just to give you some
sense of what we used,
we've got a Raspberry Pi
here running Android Things,
a very lightweight device.
This device actually sat
on a number of pilot buses,
and we used this
device at the edge
to effectively replace
this ruggedized Windows PC.
So that device was able to
take engine diagnostic data
off the CAN bus, which is where
we basically have a vehicle
controller that uses a
proprietary protocol,
and then pulls that data
into this CAN card device,
and ultimately pushes this to
our Android Things Raspberry
Pi.
So if you know
anything about Things,
you know that it's a powerful
piece of hardware that can also
support, depending on
what implementation of Pi
you put, but can also
support doing some processing
at the edge.
And so our validation here was
proving that we could pull data
into IoT Core, implementing
that through a data engineering
environment, and proving
that we could classify
data to eventually be part of
developing a machine learning
model to support vehicle
prognostics or diagnostic data.
And so we completed that project
in a very short period of time,
about four weeks.
And we were able to
settle nerves and concerns
that, number one, a device at
the edge, which is much less
expensive, could even support
a similar type of model that
was in the visionaries'
head for this,
but also that we could support
the same level of service
quality and prove value
in an innovative service
like prognostics and
machine-learning-type services
to ultimately improve the value
of the product to the market.
And just to give you some
idea of the sophistication
of this vision, ADO actually
built out a comprehensive kind
of layout here of
what the architecture
could look like in the future.
And this is ideally what I
want you to focus on here
is that what we're
trying to do, when
you try to validate a
system like this, is really
understand, what's the
most impactful business
solution that you want to
put in front of your users
and/or back to the business?
And how can you surface
that in the simplest way?
A three to four-week
project, you're
not going to solve
the entire problem.
But you'll get a very
good sense of the impact
of how you could deploy this
and how you can implement this
to support a much more
comprehensive business case,
and then take that
learning to how
it fits into your overall
road map strategy.
So we were able to prove
both of these points
on the machine learning side, to
support future SIIAB features,
and also how to use common
analytics services to support
larger business
intelligence, and eventually
surface that to the customer
and back to the business.
All right.
You got that one.
FRASER MACDONALD: Thanks, Rick.
OK.
So best practice number three--
partition your problem.
And this is one that we've
talked a bit about already.
This is a pretty simple concept
that can save you a ton of time
as you're working
through, what do
we really want to replatform?
When you take a look
at an IoT solution,
it's possible to break
it down into pieces.
And generally, those pieces
follow some consistent buckets.
You've got your devices and
your device communication.
You've got your users
and their applications
and their permissions.
You've got your
third-party integrations.
And then you've got your
data lake and your analytics
going on in the cloud.
And when you take a look at
an architecture like this,
the pieces start to tease apart.
And so if you're sitting down
with your team and thinking,
we're not able to
scale fast enough.
Or, it requires a manual
provisioning every time
we install on-site.
Or, we need to
launch a new feature,
but we don't have an
integration with a partner.
Or, we're not really
happy with the way
that our apps are
set up right now.
Chances are you're talking
about one specific piece
of this technical architecture.
You don't need to rip and
replace absolutely everything.
You can be pretty tactical
about how you do it.
So if you take a look
at this diagram here,
this is an example architecture
for how an IoT product might be
set up on GCP using GCP Tools.
On the left-hand side,
you have IoT Core,
which is our product for
connecting to devices.
And there are a lot of
fantastic products inside
of GCP for data ingestion.
What's unique about
IoT Core is that it's
purpose-built for
bi-directional communication
and with devices at the edge.
So just two things-- it does
messaging back and forth
with these devices, and it
provides them a secure identity
that they can use inside the
rest of the GCP ecosystem.
Then, the rest of the products
of storage, compute, analytics,
are ones that you might
be familiar with from GCP.
On the right-hand
side are the ones
that you might be
using for your users.
You might be building
something on App Engine,
or you might, as
we'll hear about,
be building something
using Firebase.
So to illustrate this
story a little bit better,
I'd like to invite Dallas up.
And Dallas is with
a company called
Owlet, who's gone
through exactly
this kind of consideration
quite recently.
Thanks a lot, Dallas.
DALLAS HAUETER: All right.
Apparently down, not up.
All right, so I am from Owlet.
As you can see here, we're
a health technology company
founded in 2013.
The amazing thing about
Owlet is that we actually
can provide useful information
to parents at the right time.
And what we anticipate
being able to do
is to change the way
people or parents
worry about their babies
by being able to tell them
if their baby is OK.
In 2013, our founders
had a problem
that they wanted
to solve, and that
was to know if their
babies coming home
from the hospital that
were in the NICU were OK.
And they've been monitored
for months at the NICU,
but when they came home,
they didn't have anything
to tell them if they were OK.
All of a sudden, they
were on many monitors,
and then overnight, they
didn't have a monitor at all.
And so parents are worried.
Now, that's one use case.
And then there's
a use case where,
everybody knows who has kids,
is my baby still breathing?
And going into the room,
creeping in and kind of seeing
if the baby is breathing and
not getting enough sleep.
And so our product is
able to provide that data
to customers and
to these parents
so they get the rest they need.
And it's an amazing
thing that we
can provide for our customers.
Right now, last night, there
were over 75,000 babies
being monitored by our monitor.
And if you do the math, that's
about 5 billion heartbeats
in a given night
that we are counting,
and we are collecting
all of that data.
We are collecting that data
and putting it into BigQuery
to run analysis on different
types of profiles of babies
that we can find.
And what we had to do back in
2013 was focus on our product.
We, as a company,
don't want to worry
about the connectivity
engine behind it.
And so we really want
to focus on our product
and what we can provide
to our customers.
And so I kind of want to
elaborate a little bit more
on how we partition
our problems.
And before deciding
on a replatforming,
I'm going to give you a scenario
here with our company history.
Where we first
provided our product,
it was a simple monitor on the
baby's foot to a mobile device.
And if anyone knows
hardware, that's
a Bluetooth module on the
foot to your mobile device.
Just think about it.
How much range are you going
to get if your signal is
detuned by a fleshy foot?
Well, we realized--
not as quickly
as we should have-- that we
needed to have a gateway.
And so when we decided that
we needed to have a gateway,
we decided to go with
a technology partner
to help connect our
device to the cloud.
And so with that, we were
able to kind of leave
the connectivity to
our partners and then
focus on our core product.
But as we continue
to grow, we really
want to be able to focus on
the next problem we have.
We want to be able to scale.
We really want a
monitor to go home
with every baby that's going
home from the hospital.
And in the US, that's 4
million babies a year.
And so as we want
to scale, we need
to look at being able to provide
a product that can actually
go to every baby.
And the problem
we have right now
is that as we focus
on our product itself,
who's focusing on
the connectivity?
And who's focusing
on that ability
to scale, and to
talk to every parent,
and talk to every monitor?
And so we really want to
now look at our problem
as, how do we solve our
connectivity problem
with our platform?
Our architecture is
a simple architecture
that is, I would say, like just
any other connected device,
where you have your
device management
and your authentication,
and you want to pass data
to and from your device.
In our mobile application,
which I'll just kind of show you
here, we actually
provide that data.
And then from that
mobile application,
you can control the device.
And so our goal in
replatforming is
being able to modify our product
on our needs and our schedule.
And so when we look
at our problem,
we say, what isn't
working for us now?
Instead of trying
to take the whole--
go to the heavy side of
things with your timeline
and try to re-architect
it all at once,
we take one aspect of our
product and move it over.
That makes it better for
us, so that we can actually
meet our mission of
providing information
to parents at the right time.
And so our first thought there
is, how can we be more agile?
And how can we actually
rely on third parties
as partners in our product, not
just throw it over the fence?
Here, I need a connectivity!
Throw it back.
And it's just a
generic solution.
But how can we utilize third
parties as our partners
where they support
our mission as well,
and that they can actually
move at our own pace?
And so what we want to do
is take the problem chunk
by chunk.
And our first pass was
to take our user database
and bring that under our
control, where we can actually
have better features that
support our customers.
With an out-of-the-box option,
it gets us to market quicker.
But it doesn't necessarily
meet the needs of our users
in the long term.
And so we take one aspect over.
And right now we're
in the process
of migrating our users
to a user database that's
run out of Firebase.
And it was built in Google.
And so as we take that
on, we can control it,
and we can modify
it to our needs,
as opposed to relying on a third
party that is out of the box.
And so looking to
the future is being
able to own our own
destiny and develop
a product that meets
our needs, as well
as the needs of our customers.
And so by partitioning
it and focusing
on one aspect at
a time, you'll be
able to make
modifications and improve
your features without causing
angst on your customers.
Because I can tell you this--
the worst thing about not having
control of your own platform
is a real scenario with
75,000 moms with babies
who have little sleep,
and all they want to know
is if their baby is OK.
And instead of
going into the room,
they want to open the app
from the comfort of their bed,
and then they get a message
saying, oh, the device
can't be reached.
Not being able to
control that time
is the worst for
us as a company,
and it's terrible
for our customers.
And so we want to be able
to control our platform
and control the
uptime and control
the SLAs and the features that
are there, because what happens
when someone pushes an
update on a generic system
at 9:00 PM at night?
And that's when all
of our customers
are trying to access the
app is at 9:00 PM at night.
And so if we leave that
to somebody else, who
are more of third parties,
it's a detriment to us.
And so we want to be able to
partition that problem as well
and attack it to improve
the customer satisfaction
and improve the
overall information
we can provide to our customers.
FRASER MACDONALD:
Thanks, Dallas.
And Dallas will be coming back
up in a minute for the Q&A.
So questions you've
got about that process,
he'll be back up here.
So let's take a look
at one last story
before we have our
panelists come up.
And the learning on this
one is follow the ROI.
And what we mean by this
is during any conversation
around replatforming,
adding new technology,
moving something to the
cloud, switching providers,
there's going to be a
point at which you sit down
and determine, what's it
going to cost us versus
what's it going to gain us?
And for a lot of IoT products,
the first round of their launch
is highly experimental.
I've been surprised at
the amount of customers
that we've talked to who have
been very honest in saying,
the first time we launched
something that was connected,
it was just because
our competitor launched
something that was connected.
Or, the first time
we launched it,
it was because we thought
it was a cool idea,
and we wanted to see if
we could figure it out.
But over time, if you get
to the point in maturity
with your product that you're
thinking about a replatforming,
it's because your company
has found some value from it.
Now, this is a statistic that
came out fairly recently, which
is that 1% of gathered data
is properly analyzed and made
use of in IoT devices.
Which sounds shocking,
but when you consider
that you're launching
a device that's
connecting to the internet,
your first impulse
is, let's wire up
absolutely everything
and collect it into a data
lake, and we'll figure out
what to do with it later.
It becomes a bit clearer
it's not the right way
to approach the problem.
The next estimate is 75% of
IoT initiatives are failing.
And that one's even
more surprising.
But they both come
from the same place.
When this is discussing
IoT initiatives,
it's not talking
about products that
are out there in the field.
It's talking about that
kind of thinking around,
maybe we should
connect it because!
Or, maybe we should connect
it because our competitor has.
Or, maybe we should
collect a bunch of data
and figure out what to
do with it in retrospect.
And they sit in these cycles
where nobody goes back
for reevaluation.
And the learning
from this one is,
if you're at the point where
you're thinking about adding
a new technology, you're
probably also at the point
where you can tell, where's
my business model in here?
And for a lot of companies,
it comes from different ways.
It could be that you've added
a feature that allows you
to sell the product for more.
It could be that
you've added something
that allows you to differentiate
the product in the market.
Could be that you've
converted what was previously
a device that people bought
into a service that people had--
recurring basis.
Maybe you figured out how
to make a repair service out
of whatever your consumer
or commercial product is.
Or maybe you figured out how
to make a third-party network
of vendors and operators and
repair people and installers
that you can sell
repair data to.
At the end of the day, a
lot of the IoT products
that launch and get to
the point of replatforming
know that in the
back of their heads.
And so the suggestion,
when you're
thinking about replatforming,
is follow exactly that.
Don't go for a wholesale.
Work on the technology that's
driving where your company's
value is coming from.
So these are some of
the classic use cases
from the ROIs of
a product that you
might want to double down on.
You can probably take
a look at your product
and figure out, which
aspect of this technology
is the one that's really
driving our new feature
or our ability to
deliver a product
as a service with high
uptime and availability?
Or, is this allowing
us to run our product
at lower cost to ourselves?
So make sure that
your replatforming
is themed around that.
So for a final story, before
we bring up our panelists,
I want to invite up Paul.
And he's going to
talk to us about a use
case that was exactly like this
with a product called Skykit.
PAUL LUNDBERG: Thank you.
Hey, everyone.
Paul Lundberg from Agosto.
So we were talking to
a customer one day,
and they basically
started to ask
for what they thought
was an application,
and what we quickly
viewed as a product.
And so we went out to try to
help them find the product,
because it didn't make sense
to build it for one customer.
And we found that what
they were asking for just
wasn't out there in the market.
And so we couldn't
help ourselves
but to start to investigate
this and to go down
the path of starting
to build out what
we thought could be a product.
So it's a digital
signage solution
that is built entirely on
Google and uses Chrome OS
as the endpoint media player.
So there's a lot
of people out there
that love Chrome OS for
its security and lower cost
and manageability.
And so we started to
go down that path.
We had a lot of
experience with Chrome OS.
We had a lot of experience
developing on Google's cloud.
And there were only
600 other companies
with digital signage products.
So we thought, why not?
We'll jump in and give it a go.
So based on Chrome
OS, we started
with a microservices
architecture--
I'll go into a little
more detail on that--
entirely built on
Google Cloud Platform.
And I'll get into
this a little more.
Some of the learnings that
we really kind of already
knew from doing product
development for other companies
is that building a product,
it's continual redevelopment.
I mean, the technology changes.
The requirements change.
The scaling of the
product changes.
And so you're continually
just looking at, how do we--
and as everyone has talked about
so far that's been up here,
how do we incrementally
move this product forward?
And you know, we've got
the plane in the air,
and we have to do this live.
So let me just show
you roughly what
our very high-level
architecture looks like.
So in the big blue box here, we
have a few of the microservices
that we built out initially.
One was responsible
for managing content.
Customers create
content, format content,
and they want to schedule
that to play on players,
put it in playlists, set
all kinds of rules and tags
about where that's
going to play.
And then Skykit Admin Service
is another microservice
that is all about abstracting
the device management
and make it really
straightforward for customers
to manage their
fleet of devices.
Behind the scenes, we're
interfacing with Chrome device
management, interfacing
with a logging service.
And largely, this
architecture is
very much like a
mobile architecture,
in that we couldn't always count
on our devices being online.
So we had to think about that.
In retail, or many of the
places where these devices go,
connectivity is an
issue in terms of Wi-Fi.
It's going down.
It's coming back.
We need to be able to
always play the content.
When we have the opportunity,
pull the content down.
Be ready to play whatever
updated content there
is that's available.
So we had a microservices
architecture,
devices on the edge.
We were doing push
notifications using
Google Cloud Messaging, very
much a mobile architecture
platform.
And so then, at that time,
when we built this product,
Google's cloud platform
was very different
in terms of the
services available.
So as an example, we didn't
have Pub/Sub available to us.
And IoT Core was not available
yet to handle MQTT messaging.
So when those started
to come around,
and as we were building our
own experience around IoT
and other projects, we
started to really think
about this product as
being really an IoT
product in that we've got
a lot of devices out there
that we're trying to manage.
And so we started
thinking about,
how do we start to move
this architecture into more
of an IoT pattern?
And how do we
leverage the services
that are available
on Google's cloud?
So this isn't a picture of
the entire architecture.
This is really drilling down
into more of a view of IoT.
So we have our
Skykit player, which
is a media player, HDMI
cable driving a panel.
A big change is
that everything we
were doing up until the
new architecture was HTTP.
And MQTT is a lower-level
protocol, very good for IoT,
in that we can
maintain a connection
as long as we have it and have
traffic flowing both ways.
It's a much lighter protocol
in terms of the overhead.
And it also gives us, with
IoT Core, a much better model
for security, in
terms of us securing
each individual device,
and really turning
some of that responsibility
over to Google,
in terms of their underlying
IoT Core offering.
So our general philosophy
in developing products is--
use what's available as core
components on Google's cloud
and build what you have to.
And when Google comes
out with a service,
where they're taking
responsibility
for the scaling and
all the complexities,
then move to that, and don't
support that code anymore
that you developed
in a custom way.
So what's really important
with the new architecture
is that now that our product's
becoming more complex,
and we're looking
at adding to it.
Instead of just a
couple microservices
that are communicating
between one another,
we have more microservices
that are going
to be coming into the picture.
And what's really great
about IoT Core and Pub/Sub
working in conjunction
is that as messages
come into the system
through IoT Core
and get put onto
Pub/Sub queues, we
can have multiple
subscribers to that data.
So now, if, for
example, we have,
let's say, player state, what's
going on with the player,
coming in through Cloud Pub/Sub,
both the Skykit admin, which
is responsible for devices,
and the content manager,
where we want to show
in the UI to a user what
the state of a device is, we
can just have both of them
subscribe and show that.
We don't have to have it
come in through Skykit admin
and then make sure
we communicate
that to content manager.
So it's a much more
scalable solution.
It also gives us
the opportunity to--
as an example, let's take data
and just move it into BigQuery.
Let's have multiple
subscribers, where we can just
have another
subscriber to that data
and start to look
and think about how
we can use that stream of
data in a different way.
So our learnings
out of all of this
were just continual
redevelopment--
have that kind of mindset.
We're also trying to position
our product so that we
have a lot of flexibility.
So where's the ROI?
We don't know exactly.
But we know that we want to
be as flexible as possible.
So as an example, we had
a customer come to us--
in fact, now our
largest customer--
that said, well, we really
like your Skykit product.
It's built on Chrome.
Problem is, we've got 10,000
devices deployed today that are
running on an Android device.
So what we did then was to
rebuild just that player
component.
If you remember the bigger
architecture picture,
the player is just
one component.
We were able to
redevelop that in Android
and connect it and
get that working,
so that we could win that deal.
So we don't know exactly
what the future holds.
But we know that if we
can architect our system
to be as flexible as possible,
that another opportunity might
be a panel provider that
says we have a system on chip
in our panel, and if you could
develop it in a certain way,
then we could run your
product, and we could
help you sell your product.
When we have a big deal,
we could bring that to you.
So we know that by being
as flexible as possible
and having an
architecture that supports
us moving quickly and supporting
as many different possibilities
as we can, that we're
likely to have success.
So Fraser, I think you're
going to open up the panel.
FRASER MACDONALD: Sounds great.
OK.
I think we'll keep
using this one too.
Thanks a lot, Paul.
So I'm going to invite a
couple panelists up now.
One is Dallas, who
you've heard from.
And Paul, representing Skykit.
And as well, we've
got the pleasure
of welcoming Verne up from ADO.
So these are three
people who have
gone through
replatformings themselves,
and their companies have taken
a look at the ups and downs
and walked through it.
And we'll get a chance to ask
them some practical questions
from it.
I'll hand some mics to you guys.
So I'll kick us off with a
question for each of you.
And Verne, if you want to take
a moment to introduce yourself
as we go along as well.
The first question
that I'm wondering
is, what was that moment like?
Because a lot of replatforming
products start with the worry
that you're wasting
your time, or you're
spending it inefficiently,
or something
could go wrong along the way.
What was the moment that
really tipped the scales, that
told you, no, this
investment is worth
what we're putting into it?
VERNE LIZANO POVEDANO: OK.
Good afternoon.
Well, we started with this
project about 12 years ago.
We decided to create a
kind of open platform
that can be used for the
telematics of the group.
So we started installing all
of this in about 4,000 buses.
Over the years, we have
been working with this.
But at some point, we were not
able to construct more things
over this platform.
So it became something
that was a black box,
where we cannot
do something new.
When you came with
us, we discovered
that we had an opportunity
for changing things.
And the first step
that we did is
to try to create a small
bullet tracer, as you said.
And with this bullet
tracer, we identified
that there was no
risk, no real risk,
in following this methodology
and in creating an IoT
platform, an open platform,
in the existing hardware.
So right now we feel
pretty confident that it
is the time to scale this.
And we hope that in
the following months
we're going to be
able to set up all
of this platform
in some more buses.
So we are ready for that.
We feel more confident.
I'm still working
for the company.
So I'm not getting fired yet.
And I'm pretty
sure it's not going
to happen because we feel
we are in very good hands.
And the methodology is
one that is telling you,
you can go to the next step
and to the other steps.
So we feel very
confident on that, yes.
FRASER MACDONALD: It's the
same just for each of you.
What was that moment
like that tipped
the scale for a replatforming?
DALLAS HAUETER: I think it's
been an evolution over the five
years that Owlet
has been around.
As I said when I spoke
earlier, that as we focused
on the beginning, on
launching our pulse oximetry,
and that data that we're trying
to provide to our customers,
once we kind of got our
feet underneath us on that,
we then started seeing
where else we could improve.
And that's the next
part of our product
is really how the data
gets to the customer.
We can provide the data now.
We have accurate data.
And so once we were
confident that that is there,
obviously we'll improve
that even of itself.
But we started seeing--
we call it the forest--
we start chopping
down the big trees.
And then you start seeing
what else is growing up.
And the biggest tree
next was our platform.
And so that's what
we're doing is
we're taking one
tree down at a time.
PAUL LUNDBERG: And I'd answer
that by saying that initially,
when we're building
the product, we're not
thinking about scale as much.
We just want to see it work for
a customer, two customers, 10
customers.
And so we're focused a
lot on the application
and is it functioning.
And is it doing what
the customer's wanting
and expecting it to do?
Does it have the right features?
Can we compete?
And then the
tipping point for us
is really when your primary
worry is about scale.
So the product is working.
Customers are
reasonably satisfied.
There's an endless road
map of features to build.
But the thing that could really
get us is if we can't scale,
and if we can't move quickly
to address concerns as we
see them, in terms of scaling.
And with this type of solution,
it's about device management.
It's about having the
data to answer questions.
It's about having good data
about device state and things
like that.
So when we really started to
think about re-architecting,
it was really around,
the product works.
It looks like it's a go.
But how are we going to scale?
FRASER MACDONALD: So I'll
take a second, if there's
a question from the audience,
before another question
for our panelists.
There's a microphone
just up here for anyone.
So I'll ask you a
question, Verne, about ADO.
You had a decision to
migrate your back office
for your operations
to Google Cloud.
And what do you
think was the biggest
impact of moving your back
office from where it was before
into a cloud-based operation?
VERNE LIZANO POVEDANO: OK.
The first one was about cost,
because our platform is based--
typically the standard platform
based on local computers,
local servers.
And this is very,
very expensive.
Any time you require some more
processing computing power
or some data storage, you need
to buy some more computers.
This is not anymore the
case with the cloud.
So in terms of cost, it
has a huge, huge impact.
The other one is about ubiquity.
We have operations in different
cities around the world.
And the thing here is that
it is absolutely wonderful
not having to go to
Spain or other countries
and installing infrastructure.
Since everything is
already in the cloud,
you're able to go anywhere.
And the third thing
is about connectivity.
Most of our customers
are not only the ones
who are traveling with us in
the buses but also the cities.
And the cities today, we
all know that what they want
is open data.
So the connectivity provided
by the cloud is amazing.
And we don't have to do
anything by ourselves.
We don't need to
develop new technology.
develop anything
for providing this open
data to the cities.
FRASER MACDONALD: Thanks.
So for you, Dallas,
on a specific point,
you're in the middle
of migrating your user
applications.
And you mentioned
that you've never
really seen a
difficult-to-please group
of users until you've seen
tired, frustrated parents who
just want to make
sure their baby is OK.
So this is a really
strategic, but it's also
a really sensitive
project for you.
So as you were
going into it, what
were some of the
considerations that you
had about migrating
user applications
and mobile applications
on something that's
already out there in the field?
DALLAS HAUETER: So that's
a very good question, when
it comes to, how do you
handle stressful parents?
And so I think
what we're doing is
we're trying to release it at
the same time as new features.
And so at this time
we launch this,
we're actually launching
a brand-new product.
And we're also
going into the UK,
coming at the end of the year.
And with that move, we're
going to kind of marry that
with the improvements for GDPR.
And so if we were
just to say, hey,
because it's a pain right
now with our platform,
let's move over.
It's kind of hard to sell
the reason why you have
to set up your device again.
Essentially, this
replatforming, unfortunately,
causes the old system
to not work, and then
the new system to take over.
So we don't want to upset
our parents, our customers,
too much.
But we're also not
going to force them.
So on this move,
this replatforming,
it's a slow migration.
We will actually
have our product
in the current app still
available for six months.
And then we'll push our
customers towards it.
So they choose when they
do the replatforming,
so that it's not
a critical time.
Sometimes parents
aren't using the app
until they get a notification
that something's wrong.
And so it would be
the worst experience
to get a notification
on your device,
and then go to your app, and
it's like, oh, it doesn't work.
Sorry.
You needed to
download the new one.
So we don't want that to happen.
And so it's two-sided.
We marry it with new features,
new products, hey, new things!
Here, now let's replatform.
And then also don't push
them, and do a slow rollout.
FRASER MACDONALD: Great.
Thanks.
And Paul, a question for
you on customers as well.
You talked a bit about how the
technology changes you made
allowed you to roll
out in new sites
and with new pieces of hardware.
What about on the
customer side of things?
How do you sort of
draw the dotted line
between technical improvements
and customer happiness
for Skykit?
PAUL LUNDBERG: So Skykit's
a software as a service,
so our customers really don't
know or necessarily understand
the details about how
we deliver our product.
So for us, it's just
about dependability.
So early on, we had some issues
with players being offline,
for example, with no
connectivity, where
in our application,
it would say, well,
our last known state
is that it was up.
But there were delays of
where state would be correct.
So it's really about, for
making an architecture that's
going to make the
product better,
is one that is going
to provide accurate
information about
exactly what's going
on with the devices in a
fairly complex architecture.
FRASER MACDONALD: Sure.
Thanks.
So we have time for a
question from the audience,
if we have one.
And if not, I'll wrap
up with a question
for each of our panelists here.
And thank you again
for your time.
OK.
If everyone's set
here, so a finishing
question for our panelists here.
You've all gone through,
or are in the middle
of a replatforming
process yourself.
And some of the
folks in the audience
are curious about
exactly that, which
is why they're at this talk.
If you had to offer a tip
up to another company that
is thinking about the
process right now,
or knows it might come down the
road, what would be something
you'd say?
Now, that I'm on the other
side, I wish I knew that.
What would be your tip
for a company thinking
about a replatform?
Paul, I'll hand
off to you first.
PAUL LUNDBERG: OK, sure.
Well, I would say
that a theme I think
you've heard with all these
examples, and all our stories,
are that you want
to figure out how
to incrementally go after this.
I think it's important
to just identify,
what do we go after first?
And there can be a lot of
different ways to look at that.
One, I think one of
the examples was, well,
let's look for where we
have a big problem, where
replacing that part
of the application
could really help us.
Another might be to just pick
something straightforward,
to get things underway.
A lot of times, you need to
set this up and convince people
other than the technical team
that there's an investment
to be made, and you want
to show some success.
So there's lots of
different reasons.
But those are a few I'd offer.
DALLAS HAUETER: What I would
offer is, in any company,
you're trying to
grow your business.
So if you know it's coming,
it's inevitable, don't wait.
Start now.
And that's, granted, take
it by piece by piece.
But start now, because
the more and more angry
parents that you have with
the current situation,
it just gets worse and worse.
And so you want to start now.
Please your customers.
And do the best that you can.
We're going to do
that with the UK.
Instead of going and launching
our old system on it,
we're going to launch
the new system.
Like, just restaging
it out, because we
would get into the same boat.
If we launch UK
with our old system,
we're going to have
the same problems.
We're going to
have to replatform.
So launch now.
So start now.
VERNE LIZANO POVEDANO: Well,
I guess the first thing
is to ask the right question.
What is the reason
for replatforming?
Is this because you have
technology that is becoming
older?
Technology is going to
become older any time.
Since the first deployment
you have, after this,
it's going to be
older and older.
So I guess the
right question here
is, what is the service,
what is the kind of service
that I want to propose to
my customers in the future,
knowing that the world
is changing very fast?
In our case, the
question was, what
is the competitiveness that I'm
going to have with my customer
cities in the future
if I don't have an IoT
platform for offering
them new possibilities?
So in our case, it's not
because of technology.
It's because we are
not going to have
something valuable
to propose them
in the very, very near future.
So that's why we are
starting right now.
It's a question of
survival of the business.
FRASER MACDONALD: Well,
Paul, Dallas, Verne,
thank you again for joining us.
And to everyone in the
audience, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]